ah ah ah ah
[Música]
boa noite gente eu sou a ele então eu
tenho uma pergunta pra fazer pra vocês
já pararam para pensar é quais foram as
influências que mais marcaram a vida de
vocês que mais afetaram ou como a
história de vocês pode influenciar a
vida de várias outras pessoas
às vezes eu fico refletindo que às vezes
coisas que a gente passou lá no passado
histórias que a gente venceu lá quando a
gente era muito jovem
a fé afetaram e diretamente em quem nós
somos hoje no que fazemos em como e como
vemos o mundo ao nosso redor
quando eu era muito novo eu tive uma
experiência muito rica de de participar
de manifestações instrução que eu admiro
muito que tem dois pilares um pilar é o
é o serviço e outro para proteger que
sem sombra de dúvidas moldaram a pessoa
com quem eu sou hoje
pra mim a minha família foi a primeira
grande referência que eu tive na minha
vida eu acho que a família é a base de
qualquer sociedade para que todo
indivíduo possa se desenvolver
a família é sem sombra de dúvidas é é o
primeiro é o primeiro passo para que
isso aconteça mas família não não são só
as pessoas literalmente que estão no
nosso estado nosso redor pessoas que têm
o mesmo sangue que a gente mas família
também pode ser um grupo de pessoas que
determinado momento alguém que
determinado momento ou de forma contínua
acompanha a gente ao longo da vida
essa instituição que o que eu fiz parte
tem muito orgulho de falar sou 7
batalhão de polícia militar e quando
tinha 12 anos eu comecei a vender picolé
lá e foi pela primeira vez na minha vida
que eu comecei a prestar contas e firmar
um compromisso com pessoas que não eram
da minha família porque quando eu entrei
lá dentro com um mês depois houve uma
troca de comando as coronel ricardo
quemento lobasso escura e o coronel
sérgio afonso mendes fez o combinado
comigo e aí pelezinho tudo bem
falei tudo bem coronel é você vende
picolé quito mas tal que autorizou o
leilão foi o antigo coronel tudo mais
então vou fazer um combinado ao final de
cada bimestre você tem que gostar seu
boletim para continuar vendendo picolé
aqui gente foi a melhor coisa que
fizeram na minha vida porque é muito
novo
eu costumo brincar e falar que é esse
aprendizado acho que o batalhão trouxe
pra mim naqueles três anos que eu fiquei
lá dos 12 aos 15 sobre as duas foi um
negócio muito mas muito rico sem sombra
de dúvidas e aí foi o tempo foi passando
e em paralelo a isso eu acho que os eua
influenciado muito pelo meu pai eu
sempre tive a ver um pouco empreendedora
e eu tive uma idéia de como é que eu
posso investir uma grana que eu tinha
grana que eu ganhava eu comecei a criar
um ou comecei a fornecer 2012 para
continuar uma igreja e pensei que fosse
isso cresceu porque não posso criar uma
mini fábrica de doces e tudo mais e tal
foi quando um ano e meio tinha mais de
22 pontos de vendas e fornecia pra mais
mil doces grandes esses dois com
brigadeiro beijinho de coco casos em
casadinho pra 22 pontos de vendas
diferente aonde eu pagava mexer para
poder fazer uma vilã que ajudava um
amigo também que ajudava na logística
das entregas
isso desde é tanto picolé quanto o o
oeste a fábrica de doce eu tinha tinha
12 anos mas acho que essa veia
empreendedora meu pai eu acho que uma
outra otani ponte que acha que aconteceu
na minha vida
eles sempre tiveram uma grande
preocupação ensinar os filhos o valor do
trabalho e do dinheiro meu pé padeiro e
66 técnica de saúde bucal e eu tenho um
irmão mais velho que faz sistema de
informação da uff
meu pai com oito anos de idade ofereceu
pra gente ele sempre ia vender é a água
refrigerante da praia de saquarema foi
quando ele ofereceu pra gente seguinte
era porque vocês sempre ficam próximos
da barraca porque vocês não oferece para
as pessoas que vão chegar aqui e o lucro
fica para vocês eu não criei uma grana
bacana
cheguei primeiro falou cara vamos
investir um pouco a esse time voltará
não você tá louco
mesmo um pouco mais conservador aí falam
do conservadorismo acho que eu sou um
cara que arrisca um pouquinho mais e aí
eu sozinho rpg que ele era grande mas
tínhamos ganhado nuca e três vezes mais
eu costumo brincar e falar que depois
dessa experiência voltei pra casa
querendo vender a minha mãe porque eu
comecei a vender bolinha de gude na
porta de casa sacolé picolé dos 8 aos 12
estava lá tinha fazer uma série de
coisas para poder vender o ferro velho
mas pensando até quando ficar vendendo
picolé no 7º batalhão foi quando cheguei
eu cheguei em 2010
eu parei muito
coloquei a cabeça no lugar e fazer o
seguinte eu já tenho os doces que me
traz uma quantidade de dinheiro
bacana então acho que o acho que está na
hora de eu deu literalmente abrir mão do
batalhão e começar a estudar que atentou
as minhas bases era o o hotel em
educação formal que minha família sempre
valorizou muito mas principalmente
educar e também valorizaram muito aquela
educação que uma educação que você
aprende dentro de casa né eu acho que
hoje está tá tão em crise quanto à
educação formal que a educação do trato
da valorização das pessoas
e foi assim que eu pensando até quando
ficar vendendo porque era minha vida eu
passei no curso técnico está nesse curso
técnico e eu comecei a colocar metas na
minha vida em relação aos seus estudos e
decidir que eu queria ser um baita aluno
e foi respostas começaram a se abrir e
começou a adquirir a consciência que
embora o trabalho é o batalhão os doces
ea minha família construir as bases e
construir parte de quem eu sou hoje dos
meus valores só a educação poderia
potencializar tudo que eu poderia fazer
e foi assim que eu comecei algumas
bolsas tiveram duas bolsas
até os meus 18 anos foram muito
diferenciadas o meu ganha uma bolsa da
embaixada americana de um programa
chamado programa access e o outro é foi
quando o 3º ano do ensino médio teve a
oportunidade de estudar na escola parque
da gávea e eu morava em são gonçalo
e aí tudo na sua vida tem dois lados né
costumo brincar falar que tem sempre o
passivo e ativo né e o pessoal de
contabilidade economia tem um pouquinho
melhor
o ativo é sempre aquilo que você vai ter
que sacrificar pra poder a coisa
acontecer
o meu passivo naquele momento ela acorda
às 4 da manhã 4 40 pegar o ônibus para
às 7 horas na escola para sair da escola
às cinco horas da tarde chegar em casa
oito e meia da noite
então o daquele momento esse é o meu
parceiro meu partido também era perder
eu tinha defasagem conhecimento mas até
aí tudo bem eu acho que a oportunidade
surge a gente tem que pegar em abraçar
durante três meses não fiquei fazendo
esse e se essa logística que acabei de
falar pra vocês foi quando voltei à
minha antiga escola conversando com mais
professora minha e perguntei para ela é
e conversando com ela perguntou e aí
sofreu preconceito acontecer alguma
coisa mas eu falei na opção graças a
deus nada a escola parque uma escola
construtivo
escolas com seus vícios vamos ter um
ensino muito diferenciado faz com que os
alunos têm uma mente muito mais aberta
ela falou que a fim de fazer a pessoa
não tem tempo de estudar foi quando
chegou ele falou cara não tem tempo da
minha irmã é diretora de uma escola
pública na zona sul tem que ser você
fica lá eu falei pô vou ficar lá na
escola pública nas ações para que o
trabalho de escola falou você vai ficar
lá não vai ficar lá como essa impressora
eu dormi lá falei dos mais ouvi lá não
fui eu com 17 anos é dormir numa escola
pública no leblon
aí você me pergunta o cara é louco por
que você aceitou fazer isso tudo mais
naquele momento pensei em duas coisas
espuma em ti quem não conhecia ninguém
ou pelo menos eu passava por equipe e é
quem própria poderá aproveitar uma
oportunidade de estudo vai dormir numa
escola pública e 2 acho que existe uma
noite no museu né
eu vou poder dormir vão ter vários
livros e tal vai ser uma aventura da
lada eu costumo brincar com meus amigos
seguinte é acho que ela estava no leblon
há três quadras da praia que dez e meia
da noite até 6 até 6 horas da manhã
ninguém tinha mais metro quadrado tão
caro para si só para morado que eu no
brasil porque já que o metro quadrado
leblon mais caro e eu tinha uma escola
inteira com maggi são a 10 salas à minha
disposição e foi uma experiência muito
bacana eu acho que eu comecei a aprender
um pouco que é a realidade da da vida
mesmo porque de 75 conviver com a
realidade é a elite brasileira e de 5 a
10 qual a verdadeira é realidade do
brasil e porque quem estuda na escola
pública no leblon à noite dez pessoas da
rocinha vidigal muzema rio das pedras as
comunidades do rio de janeiro
o aprendizado incrível no final do ano
acho que depois da tempestade vem a
bonança mas será federal no estado ao
rebouças na puc bolsa não é meu mac
tirei da redação do enem
meu objetivo sempre tinha sido entrada
de mac foi que eu entrei no mec e já
muito focado
já tinha convivido com com esses dois
mundos e tudo mais
e aí eu tive a oportunidade no
finalzinho da escola parque que envolve
muito essa questão de ir como como a
gente tem referências mas como ter
referências é importante como você dá
oportunidade para as pessoas faz uma
grande diferença eu entrei no e mec
muito focado e me tornei um total que
nunca com dois mercados financeiros e
microeconomia mais uma vez sem sombra de
dúvidas os estudos abrindo portas e foi
assim que ganhei uma bolsa prova foi
ganha uma bolsa pra de uma associação
que ajudava ajudava a estudante com
potencial em uma bolsa pra poder é falar
espanhol é aprender espanhol no clube
espanhol que tem no rio a casa de
espanha e tinha um negócio ali chamado
fundação estudar que estava na minha na
minha mente eu pensava prestar mais à
frente foi quando eu cheguei pensei o
seguinte vou começar a me aproximar mais
um pouco e participe lado liderança lá
que é hoje a liderança 16 horas 32 horas
e foi da primeira geração de
multiplicador e aí surgiu a fundação
ajuda na minha vida quando eu entreguei
a bolsa e aí foi
acho que a fundação estudar eu acho que
foi uma outra grande referência pra mim
porque a missão da fundação da geral a
oportunidade pra gente boa a gente
grande e ajudar a transformar o país
isso sim é intimamente totalmente ligado
com o ciclo de vida que eu tô vendo hoje
que o universo é que foi assim que
entrou na fundação e aí tem um negócio
que aconteceu muito bacana que uma
pessoa eu queria fazer um estágio são
paulo e de férias é uma pessoa chegou
falou pra mim que o outro tem um projeto
aqui pra você e tudo mais o tal projeto
seleção de gente pra você passar aqui um
mês um mês e meio essa pessoa ailton
cunha e aí eu fui trabalhar com ele
durante ele conhece a hilton está
apresentando aqui hoje 26 durante seis
semanas mais ou menos uma experiência
incrível e aí muito é muito muito mérito
a ele que a fundação estudar tem quando
você é muito engajado você é um líder lá
estudar foi que fui dar uma palestra
junto com nizan guanaes no dia 23 de
junho de 22 e 23 de novembro de 2015 ele
falou uma coisa que me incomodou muito
né as pessoas que poderiam os jogos que
poderia estar fazendo não estou fazendo
o brasil é um país cheio de igreja
grandiosidade outro lado cheio de
problemas então o jovem tem que assumir
a responsabilidade também para poder
ajudar o país
e aí o outro dia eu nem consegui dormir
direito fiquei pensando nossa acho que
hoje eu tenho acesso aos recursos
eu sou uma pessoa que tem uma habilidade
de conseguir mobilizar as pessoas que eu
tô fazendo o que o poder
fazer a mais que eu estou fazendo para
poder ajudar o país nesse sentido foi aí
que surgiu para o líder é o programa de
formação de lideranças jovens que que
visa é discutir o cenário atual
brasileiro junto a grandes referências
visando a criação de empreendimentos
para ajudar na transformação do brasil
eu faço uma pergunta pra vocês eu te
falei para vocês que a primeira
referência foi a minha família depois
que o batalhão depois foi à escola
parque hoje é a fundação estudar o
próprio líder o que a gente faz hoje e
sim sobre as dúvidas eu acho que começou
às no mar são muito muito muito digna
daqueles coronéis lá atrás que que
chegaram para mim falar e menino e aí
você tem que colher de chá e tudo mais
que tinha dores ou vender aqui eu
pergunto pra vocês quem são os coronéis
da vida de vocês
quem são as pessoas que no passado
fizeram é exercer alguma influência na
sua vida e que hoje de alguma forma é
até hoje afeta na sua trajetória de
forma positiva
e foi assim quando a gente embarcou pra
lhe deu entrada no processo acho que é
possível fazer esse pra gente acha que
nunca a gente está preparado e sempre a
gente acha que não é o momento certo
para poder começar a gerar transformação
tempo pra vocês neste momento certo para
gerar transformação ou então sempre ser
é será que a gente sempre vai chegar o
momento da nossa vida que a gente vai
estar preparado então com os recursos
que a gente tinha naquele momento a
gente pegou começamos a desenvolver o
projeto e um negócio cresceu de uma
maneira assim que a gente realmente não
acreditava que era a forma positiva da
gente está contribuindo para a sociedade
daquele momento eu e toda minha equipe o
negócio foi crescendo até que chegou o
momento que ele falou vamos estruturar e
vamos criar algo realmente diferenciado
aqui pra poder ajudar a formar gente
tanto na política quanto o
empreendedorismo e eu pergunto pra vocês
é quais são os grandes desafios que a
gente está passando hoje que vocês estão
passando hoje com os seus passivos que
você enfrenta hoje todo mundo da vida
sempre você vai ter seus passivos seus
ativos mas nem sempre as pessoas têm de
dizer pra gente que não é possível que
realmente você não vai conseguir mas eu
acho que basta a gente para pensar
êêê se juntar principalmente de gente
que acredita em fazer alguma coisa
realmente muito positiva em um trecho de
uma frase que eu gosto muito é que quem
fala que a paixão pelo que você faz é a
transformação que você quer gerar a luta
que você vive no seu dia a dia é tem que
ser o que te motiva e sobre as dúvidas é
isso que me motiva hoje está ajudando
fazer essa transformação está ajudando a
a a fazer isso e más mas o mais
importante disso tudo é o aprendizado do
processo eo a paixão tem que ser pela
vitória é eu pergunto a vocês quais são
os desafios com as suas batalhas que
vocês que estão escolhendo comprar poder
ajudar a transformar o país e com as
vitórias que vocês pretendem ter no
futuro
então é um negócio que realmente me toca
muito e que sem sombra de dúvidas se não
consegue fazer isso se você não se junta
com gente boa
você não consegue isso você só é grande
e ninguém faz nada sozinho né
então a gente viu aqui várias pessoas aí
eu falo seguinte é quando tive a idéia
do próprio líder teve uma pessoa que eu
fui procurar que eu achava que ela
conseguiu ajudar a desbravar a iaa a
quebrar muitas barreiras em relação às
pessoas a terem uma tensa maior em
relação ao setor público que ela já está
ótimo do vetor brasil e foi uma das
conversas mais assertivas que eu tive e
de uma outra pessoa que a gente tinha
tinha na veia aquele negócio de querer é
diversidade ver-se da diversidade ele a
questão do dn ali é de que o prazo
deveria dar seu dna
e aí foi assim que a gente procurou o
laser do pai dela e aí vamos ter
vamos ter que fazer um processo de
integração entre as pessoas e tudo mais
então procura o richie o pedro do grupo
anda que stéfany faz parte e tal aí
vamos fazer vamos a oficina estava
surgindo foi quando aílton fez uma ponte
o amigo fez a ponte falou que vai
conversar depois podem contribuir com o
processo seletivo e aprender o que eles
estão fazendo então a mensagem que eu
queria passar para vocês o seguinte
gente tem que ter referências na vida de
vocês
a vida é feita de ciclos então tem que
entender quando o ciclo começa quando o
ciclo termina costumo falar que a melhor
coisa que aconteceu na minha vida foi
ter entrado
o batalhão ea segunda melhor foi ter
saído porque se eu continuo até hoje lá
com 23 anos vendendo picolé
embora as pessoas embora vender picolés
e 1 uma uma o exercício muito digno mas
as pessoas lá mesmo estimulavam que eu
poderia fazer mais
você tem que se juntar e está perto de
quem está fazendo isso dificilmente você
vai encontrar uma pessoa que está
fazendo é que não está próxima de quem
está fazendo então para poder aprender
para poder trocar e própria de se
motivar também porque motivação negócio
que é interno é intrínseco e só depende
da gente então escolheu a vida de vocês
háháhá as batalhas que vocês querem
comprar
se é para comprar todas que vocês
realmente acredito compre vão em busca
realmente do que vocês querem e e sem
sombra de dúvidas a transformação que eu
a a grande batalha que eu decidi pra
minha vida foi ajudar a transformar meu
país e é isso que estou fazendo hoje com
23 anos
que deus abençoe a todos muito obrigado
[Aplausos]